and before we leave you tonight we have
a live look now our crew has just
arrived on the scene of this breaking
news we've been following since five
o'clock we can now tell you that the
intersection at Flamingo and Cobalt
should be opening shortly all of this
because of a suspicious vehicle that
Metro pulled over the driver began
driving erratically in this intersection
eventually was stopped right in the
middle of the road and either the car
that stopped it or the actual car they
were chasing
burst into flames so we're trying to get
some more information but we can tell
you that barricade suspect is now in
custody earlier we were looking at those
Flames from the car from the Regional
Transportation Commission fast cams from
above now on the ground with our eight
news now photojournalists and again we
are being told from our team there that
reopening is currently happening there
at Flamingo and Koval a very busy area
especially in these evening hours with
all the transportation that's happening
nearby but you see uh this is the RTC
fast cam this is the video from earlier
and you can see off in the distance of
that the fire happening in that cars we
brought it to you live on 8 News Now